il était une fois un auteur nommé jack
qui était la plus grande des arnaques
bouclé jusqu'à geler taper sur le
clavier quand s'ils doivent ou fini par
faire crac
ségou jack oui les bouquets ni ouais y'a
pas de doute on voit que vous débarquiez
de californie fait pas attention à col
c'est la première fois qu'ils font un
scénariste en chair et en os toute façon
personne ne sait jamais vraiment qui on
est alors c'est quoi ces lignes c'est ce
qu'il me reste à imaginer
et si quelqu'un était malencontreusement
enfermé dans une chambre froide par un
tueur en série qui ignorait qu'il était
dedans à quelqu'un la personne ici
que vous attendez le temps vous est
compté votre fils mort à civaux pages
ont traîné les duels tourne vite votre
histoire se grippe
pour sauver votre fils vous j'aurais en
équipe
à chaque heure d'écriture il fera plus
frisquet
mais si je sais pas très bien les petits
espaces
je veux te plaire
c'est moi qui risque le plus gros on va
bien je laissais demande on voit ta
culture
c'est une idée de scénario pour en faire
un film ça parle d'un qui enferme un
pauvre écrivain et qu'il tortue